there's a song you produced that i don't
think most people realize you produced
and uh it is this song and uh it's one
of my favorite madonna songs
oh yeah justify my love i want to kiss
you in paris
how do you come to work with madonna
that happened early in that was
right after my first tour yeah after let
love rule so that you know it was like
1990 or
and um and she's good at spotting like
who the next hot
dude is in the music business right yeah
she was uh
she was checking me out and i'd seen her
on a few occasions and
out you know in clubs and around the
world right and um
i wrote this song and i knew it wasn't
for me you wrote justify my love yeah
but you could how do you know it's not
for you
i just knew it that's weird because this
is not something i would do
do you hear it do you say something this
would be good for a female artist like
madonna yes so
yeah so had the demo made and i called
madonna
and you're on the demo you sing it yeah
i'm singing on i'm singing the
the little background melody on the on
the track
justify my yeah and uh anyway
i called her i said i have a number one
song for you and she said
sure i said you and everyone else i have
a number one song for you
and she said bring it down to the studio
so at that time i had my cassette
went down to the studio she's like let
me hear this thing i popped it in
she blasted it in the studio nobody said
anything she played it again
and she said okay let's record it wow
and so it was right then and there she
heard it all she needed to do is hear it
once
i said okay twice and that's it and and
i love it and then we got together like
you know a few days later and
did the vocal and that was it and it
went number one it was my first number
one song i wonder why people don't
realize that you produce i guess the
producer or the writer doesn't get much
credit it's always the
the artist i guess and and the end final
analysis happened a long time ago here
we go
there it is you produced it too right
yeah wow
it doesn't sound like a lenny kravitz
song no that was it
yeah very cool
that you wrote that
did you play any instruments on this um
it's all programmed
right right on this i played this the
string ensemble
what do you play that on on a synth yeah
yeah
and see while she's talking that little
background voice in the back yeah
that's you what did they speed that up
no
sticking into falsetto why you're up
high on that one
that's you yeah now that i didn't
realize
no clue that was you
[Music]
there you go again
and of course at that time you know she
made that video with jean-baptiste
mondino
yeah that at the time was was quite racy
yeah that's what you watch now it's
nothing now it's tame
but it was sexy and they wouldn't play
it on tv they banned it so madonna
is being as brilliant as she is um
had all these videos printed up and sold
it i remember there were lines around
tower records
people buying it right uh and the thing
just blew up
yeah that was your first number one
number one wow
you